or Major General Rupert Jones a former
commander of the British Army's standing
Joint Force is with us now hi
um there was a weariness when I was
speaking to the Ukrainian ambassador to
the UK yesterday how do you think it's
going
I mean it's not surprising there's a
degree of weariness you know that this
War's been going on a very long time now
and it is exhausting as as a as a
process so I suspect you feel a little
bit of that and whenever you speak to
ukrainians you get this sense of
determination but it's but it's hard
pounding
um and you know we're we're all waiting
for the for the big next move so this is
it feels a slightly uneasy phase okay um
he also said that they were preparing
for a spring offensive it's getting a
bit late in the day for that what's
going on
yeah I mean I mean it feels as though
it's coming together you know we
shouldn't underestimate how hard it
challenge this we talk about a spring
offense here because that's an easy
thing the Russians of course have used
the winter to strengthen their defensive
positions so you know when the attacker
comes it's gonna be a very very tough
thing the indications are that it's
close so the Ukrainian defense minister
has described about being in the final
stages of of preparations and it was
telling that Jen stoltenberg the NATO
Secretary General in the last few days
has made an announcement that 98 of
Western Equipment that's due to be
provided has now been provided so those
are indicators that were were to some
degree in the final stages before an
offensive not fighter jets though
um and I was speaking to Tom tug and how
it was that where you are um security
minister this morning former serving
officer as you know and he was basically
saying that we're not going to give them
a fighter jets
yeah I mean I think I think that would
that would be a mistake so the
ukrainians will need to go with what
they've got you know whatever they fight
whatever they've got now that's what
they're going to go into the fight with
the challenge are we integrating
everything everything they've got into a
proper Force it's all very well having
tanks but you've got to integrate it
into a force but I but I do think that
the West must continue to address this
fighter jet issue they're short of air
defense weapons and they're very short
of fast Jets and the perennial refrain
has been well it takes too long to train
up the ukrainians and they they use some
figures such as a year are thrown around
well we're well over a year into this
war the sooner the decision is made to
give fighter jets probably f-16s that
are on very wide uh Distribution on the
international stage the better and then
that timeline can start coming down but
they have to do this this uh offensive
without them
um history tells us that war is the one
in the air why is there such reluctance
yes
um
[Laughter]
air power is vital of course it is and
it's been very interesting in this war
so far that the air has not dominated in
the way that we thought it might so the
Russian Air Force have never kind of
dominated the skies in the way that we
thought they they might but that's been
a lot to do with it um Ukrainian uh
Ingenuity if you like
the longer this grinds on the more air
power is is important important I talked
about the really strong Russian defenses
you've got to unlock those you've got to
break through those and air power is a
really important element of that
ultimately though it's the soldier on
the ground who's gonna have to make make
the Hardy odds just remind us what
you're doing yeah
um what do you make of Russia rejecting
the US's assessment of military cash
well they would say that wouldn't they
um but both sides would say that well
indeed so I mean I think what what
whether you believe the national
security council's statement which was
20 000 dead 80 000 wounded since
December uh or whether you can question
the exact validity over the the figures
I think they're probably the best
estimate that that the West can come up
with they are indicative of a very very
high attrition rate you know the figures
we're here coming out of back moot where
the fighting has been so tough for a
great many months now you know the
Russians suffering between 6 and 10
casualties for every one Ukrainian so
you know I think those those figures
coming out of the American National
Security Council feel entirely credible
why do we continue to talk about back
mode both sides telling us it's not
particularly important and yet it's been
fiercely fought over yeah I think we
keep talking about it because it's it's
where the fighting is right now you know
since since the Christmas time that
hasn't been a huge amount of movement on
the on the front line and so if in a way
back route has become the become the
focus uh and the Russians have been
looking for their symbolic Victory even
though back moot as a town isn't that
it's significant in and of itself and of
course the ukrainians don't want to give
the Russians that symbolic Victory and
they've used back moot as a as a
location to draw in Russian forces and
drive down Whittle down Russian numbers
cause enormous attrition uh on the
Russians and that's why there continue
to be lots of talk about it and a final
thought about the unably behavior of
lukashenko
um what's the West going to do about
that I mean I you know I think they will
continue to manage it I absolutely defer
to Nato diplomats but I but I think
they'll continue to to manage that as
best they can uh and and try and prevent
you know any further escalation uh from
Belarus when I finally thought sorry I
just wanted to ask you about ammunition
stocks um well we're told that they use
up um I think I'm writing saying
something like the and our entire supply
of ammunition here in the UK could be
used up in something like 22 hours if
there was a war like we've seen yes in
the Ukraine and of course that tells you
two things firstly that the UK and many
of our our allies are woefully
underprepared and we need to commit far
more money on into these sorts of
ammunition stocks but it also tells you
the huge amounts of ammunition that are
being expended in in Ukraine I think the
ukrainians are getting through something
between four and seven thousand shells a
day the Russians about 20 000. those are
huge quantities
and and so stocks are a real problem
again the ukrainians have shown great
Ingenuity of working around their their
lack of ammunition but we the West again
have got to do more you know the
Americans are ramping up uh their their
provision uh some countries are are
going to their industrial base to
increase capacity but we need to do more